- I'm your guest host Simu Liu and with me
is fellow pretend
superhero, Kumail Nanjiani.
(audience cheers)
Now Kumail and I both have superpowers
in our recent movies,
Eternals and Shang-chi,
both on Disney Plus now,
little plug for you.
And we both grew up loving all
superheroes and comic books
and in movies.
So it's time for a game
that tests how well
we know which superpower
goes with which superhero.
This is Super Power Through It.
(bright music)
- God, are you, are you there?
- [God] Yeah, I'm here.
Hey there, fellas.
How you both doing?
- I'm doing really good.
- [God] Doing good.
Now in this game, we're gonna find out
who knows their fellow superheroes better.
Now what I'm gonna do is
describe a super power
and if you know the
superhero with that power
you're gonna buzz in and give the answer.
But if you're wrong
you're gonna have to take one
of those shots next to you.
And let me tell you, we got
some pretty nasty drinks
over there from hot dog water
to clam juice to wasabi.
So, get ready.
Now on the other hand, if
you're right, you get a point
but the other person has to take the shot.
Any questions?
I didn't think so.
Okay. Here we go.
Here's the first question.
Here we go.
This superhero has an
indestructible shield.
(buzzer beeps)
- Captain America.
(bell rings)
- [God] It is Captain America.
Simu Liu you have one point.
Come on Kumail.
- [Kumail] I can do this all day.
- [God] And this is hot dog water.
- Yeah.
- [God] That's it.
- Boba, boba, boba's right there.
- [God] What a lovely bouquet.
Hot dog water.
Where's the superpowers now, huh?
- I give up.
- [God] Yeah, well there's
still more game to go.
- Yeah, how many?
God, god, how many questions
do we have to get through?
- [God] Oh, as many, as
many as I feel like asking,
Don't worry about that.
- Fair enough, Fair enough.
- That is not a lie,
that is hot dog water.
- [God] That is hot dog water.
- Kumail this might be the first time
in game show history that I might have
to actually just let you get one.
'Cause I feel so bad for you.
Let's you know what?
Let's God show,
- [God] All right,
here's the next question.
She can control the weather
(buzzer beeps)
and can fly using the
wind that she creates.
- Who is storm?
(bell rings)
- [Simu] Wow.
- [God] Storm is correct.
And after you drink that hot dog water
you're gonna make some
wind to own over there,
I have a feeling.
So now we're tied.
- Is going to be worse than you think.
- [God] I understand.
- Imagine how awful it is
and then watch it vault
right past your expectations.
You know, I think that the key
is just to imagine it
as like a light soup.
- [Kumail] Yeah, I think that's right.
(audience applauds)
- Soupy.
It's nice, It's like,
- Your eyes are watering.
- It's nice then why are you getting that.
Let's leave that there.
- [God] Get yourself some boba.
- The aftertaste it came on.
I was trying to put on a great face.
- [Kumail] It sticks around for a while.
- [God] Are you okay?
You okay Simu?
You okay?
- I'm all right god, thank you
- [God] All right, here's
your next question now.
- [Simu] That was your one.
He has retractable
Adamantium plated parts.
- What, no, that's not cool.
- I didn't,
- (simu growls) Retractable, Wolverine.
(bell rings)
- [God] It is Wolverine.
- So Kumail, you know what time it is?
- I'll do wasabi.
- [God] Okay, all right, that's it.
- Big mistake.
(Simu laughs)
New rule.
No more, no more chasers.
- No more chasers?
- New rule.
- Why?
- Because I'm the show host now.
- [God] Here's your next question.
His anger allows him to change color
and breathe under water.
(buzzer beeps)
- Breathe under water?
- You should stop
talking when he,
- His anger?
- The Incredible Hulk.
(bell rings)
That is correct.
- Okay.
- [God] Which one?
Which one are you picking there?
Which one are you gonna do.
- I'm gonna do wasabi and water.
'Cause I'm, you know, I'm of the opinion
that Kumail is just a little whiny
and I wanna show the world,
- [God] That is true, that is true.
- That it's not actually that bad.
So here you go.
- [God] Oh, it feels so good.
(Simu coughs)
- You know what's bad about that
is that it's only now
getting to my stomach
and I'm feeling it.
It's got a project.
- Guests host the show they said.
- Yeah, why did you?
- It'll be fun, they said
- Okay
- [God] Okay.
Now this is the tiebreaker question here
because we do have a tie.
Here is the tiebreaker question.
- I'm two minutes ahead of you.
It doesn't get any better.
(audience laughs)
- He has a cloak of levitation
(buzzer beeps)
and walks through circles of energy.
- Dr. Strange.
(bell rings)
- [God] It is Dr. Strange.
- I'm sorry.
Kumail, I think if I may make a suggestion
I think America wants to see you tonguing
that ranch dressing.
- [Audience] Yeah, Ranch.
- Certainly the audience.
- [Audience] Ranch, ranch, ranch.
- It'll be nice.
It'll be a pallette cleanser.
- [Kumail] You know what,
I hate ranch dressing anyway.
- [Simu] Me too.
- [God] There it is oh,
- [Simu] Let's see the,
- [God] Oh that's good.
- There's still a little, bleep you.
It is so gross dude.
(audience applauds)
- It is so gross.
- I enjoyed that, I enjoyed the,
- Like yeah,
- [God] Well, thanks
for doing that, Kumail,
you still lost, but I
appreciate that you did that.
And Simu, you are the winner.
You have done it
- Bet you didn't see that coming.
Thank you to Kumail Nanjiani.
He was a wonderful sport.
Eternals is out on blue-ray
and DVD, February 15th.
And it's available on digital
and Disney plus right now.
And don't forget, Shang
Chi is also on Disney plus.
So that's, you know, you now know,
- Take that, take that out.
Take out, take out the Shang chi.